wir kommen zur ersten sitzung im neuen
jahr in der wir uns mit johann gottlieb
fichte reaktion auf die freiheits
debatte im ausgang von kant befassen
werden gegen uns wir hatten vor allem
skeptische tendenzen kennengelernt
dazu zählt kreuzer wir hatten aber auch
sehr radikale position kennengelernt
zu erinnern ist jan carl christian erich
schmid und seine theorie des
intelligenten fatalismus nach oben
rechts wie links entsprechend hinein und
geschichte tritt jetzt auf als ein
rezensent von kreuzes praktischen
betrachtung über die freiheit des films
diese schrift diese rezension die sehr
kurz ist die erschienen 1793 soße nicht
raus und sie jetzt noch ein bisschen was
über fichte zu beginn sagen fichte
lernte er unter prekären bedingungen als
arme hauslehrer gigantische philosophie
kennen also wichtig hat davor studiert
aber abgebrochen und war eigentlich
nicht sonderlich glücklich und seine
situation und ist dadurch dass es ein
schüler als hauslehrer ganz philosophie
erklären sollte kam er selbst auf die
spur dieses interessanten deckers und
hat sich damit zählten sie fasst er hat
dann nämlich in der folge selbst auch
werke verfasst er hat einen versuch eine
kritik alle offenbarung geschrieben sind
92 und diese schrift die wurde
irrtümlicherweise für ganz eigene
schrift gehalten die man in dieser zeit
erwartet
und so wurde sie mit einem schlag
bekannt
1794 wurde wichtel als nachfolger von
carly und reinhold auf dem wir auch noch
eingehen werden in diesem semester
professor in jena wir haben schon
kennengelernt
jena das zentrum des damaligen kann
tennis muss diese freiheits debatte mit
der wir uns befassen
die fand überwiegend in jena statt auch
andere denker wie eben ulrich und
wichtig kreuzer schmid die waren dort
alle zugang und wichtel entwickelte dann
dort in jena in der folge seine
sogenannte wissenschaft lehre
das war nicht viel los auf jeden
anschluss an eine transzendentale
philosophie die alles wissen sowohl das
theoretische wissen was wir eben wissen
können und auch das praktische wissen
was wir tun zurück bzw der subjektivität
ab leid dass ich nicht bei fichte noch
eine viel größere rolle ein als es
bekannt der fall war so sagen allein
fragen geht versucht wichtig kurzes
fazit es muss zu entgehen ist eine frage
die andere frage ist wie verhält sich
fichte zu schmieds intel ibm fatalismus
diese theorie hatten ja auch schon kurz
gehen
so jetzt will ich hier ein paar zitate
von geschichte an land wo jetzt hier an
die virtuellen und es war sagt jetzt
verfolgen dass es ist von mehreren
freunden der kritischen philosophie
erinnert und von reinhold carle und
reinhold mit dem wir ins auge fassen
allen leuten gezeigt dass man zwischen
derjenigen äußerungen der absoluten
selbsttätigkeit durch welche die
vernunft praktisch ist und sich selbst
eingesetzt gibt und derjenigen durch
wilde mensch sehe ich in dieser funktion
seien für ihn bestimmt diesen gesetzen
oder nicht sorgfältig zu unterscheiden
habe also es geht hier einmal und die
legislative funktion das sittengesetz
ist sich selbst ein gesetz geben das die
legislative dimension und hier gibt es
noch mal diese alternative oder diese
exekutive funktionen dem gesetz
gehorchen oder nicht dieses gehorchen
oder nicht das sind die da sehnt man
jetzt hier schön diese
zwei möglichkeiten der freien
entscheidung hatte sind diese alternativ
noch möglichkeiten der analytischen
debatte bezeichnete das prinzip der
alternativen möglichkeiten oder
possibilities so als wir müssen
unterscheiden zwischen der exekutive und
legislative funktion und da sagt jetzt
wichtig das sei karl donath reinhold zu
verdanken auf diesen denke gehen wir
noch genau erinnert jedenfalls noch man
diesen punkt
so jetzt aber weiter im text es gibt
noch ein weiteres interessantes zitat
verpflichtungen dass er kreuzer diese
unterscheidung ball zu beobachten
scheint bald wieder vernachlässigt und
mithin in ihrer ganzen bestimmtheit es
sicher nicht gedacht hat wollen wir
nicht trügen aber entnehmen die durch
reinhold heidenreich heimreisen weitere
denken diese debatte und zuletzt durch
ganz selbst gegebene im wesentlichen
einstimmige definition zerfall des
spiels dass dieselbe ein vermögens zeit
durch absolute selbsttätigkeit sich zum
gehorsam oder ungehorsam gegen
passierten gesetz mit in zur
kontradiktorisch entgegengesetzten
handlung stimmen als gegen das gesetz
des logischen grund es streiten
in anspruch also wir sehen hier wieder
dieses problem als wie auch schon in
anderen texten hatten
ich darf daran erinnern an gehörig nach
oben rechts doch noch gelingen zu
unrecht rein
das geht hier um das problem einmal der
kontakt zwischen entgegengesetzten lang
das ist das prinzip die alternative
möglichkeit gap und dagegen steht in
dieser ganzen debatte das gesetz des
logischen kunde das ist natürlich
logische kunde ist auch das zureichend
grunde ist das alles eine ursache haben
muss und hier das geht natürlich auf
leibnitz zurück
wir sehen hier eine spannung zwischen
diesen zwei prinzipien die wir in unsere
freiheit denken müssen einerseits die
alternativen möglichkeiten andererseits
aber auch die bestimmtheit und die
bestimmtheit der handlung und das
beliebte alternative möglichkeiten
scheint so was die in die rente zu
verlangen das wiederum macht die
freiheit allerdings nicht sehr
verständlich wir sehen hier es gibt hier
große probleme jetzt lesen wir weiter es
ist nämlich zu unterscheiden sich die
zwischen dem bestimmen als freier
handlungen des intel ibm und dem
bestimmt sein als erscheinendem zustande
es sind nicht die obens erstgenannte
äußerungen der absoluten selbsttätigkeit
des menschlichen geistes erscheint in
einer tat sei in dem stimmt sein des
oberen regierungs vermögenswertes
freilich die empfehlen muss verwächst
wenn wir nicht verwechselt aber eben zu
wenig in einer theorie des übergegangen
übergangen werden muss die
selbsttätigkeit diesem vermögen seine
bestimmte nur auf eine auf bestimmte
reformen welche als sittengesetz
erscheint die von jeder zu unterscheiden
äußerungen die absoluten selbsttätigkeit
im bestimmt des spielens erscheint nicht
und dann nicht erscheinen bei der weder
über sprünge ich-form los ist es wird
bei uns als postulat dass du jene form
des ursprünglichen regierungsvermögen
die bewusstsein gegeben mit
gesetzeslücken gesetzes angenommen und
ist demnach nicht gegenstand des wissens
seien des glaubens dieses wunderbare
mögen uns nennt man das buch regierung
zu mögen und sein charakteristischer
unterschied von dem niederen
regierungsminister dass die erste
kleiner clip gegeben wird sondern dass
es nicht selbst eins geben
die letzten aber sein objekt gegeben
werden muss das erste ist absolut
selbsttätig das letzte geleit
rücksichtlos leiden
das ist ein bezug auf sich dass kritiker
auf warum man vielleicht der unterschied
geben zwischen den brücken der unteren
regierungsvermögen übrig bedienung
vermögen das bestimmt kant in seiner
kritik der praktischen als die reine
praktische vernunft regierung zu
entscheiden ist jetzt aber hier
das kann das um regierungsvermögen mit
dem willen identifiziert hatte wichtig
schreibt jetzt hier
das ist mit dem willen nicht verwechselt
werden darf das problem war eben dass
das wenn man sagen dass bewegung
vermögen also der eigentliche willen der
entscheidet ist die reine vernunft
dann scheint daraus etwas wieder
intelligenter netze zu folgendem gerade
das thema schmid vertreten hat wenn wir
nur frei sind werden wir uns das
sittengesetz geben dann sind wir ohne
frei wenn wir uns nicht das sieht ein
gesetz geben und diese differenz
zwischen die regierung durch unfreien
will die vollzieht jetzt hier fichte in
diesem text
hier finden wir weitere interessante
bestimmungen dass der wille nicht
erscheint als ein bestimmter wille und
das vorhaben los ist dass wir da auch
noch eigens zu diskutieren fast sind
damit meint wichtig ist jetzt hier vor
allem die differenz um bestimmte
stimmungen vermögen und dem weg
ein weiteres zentrales zitat dass wir
auch noch kurz beim lesen wollen
die neigung und handys überhaupt als
bestimmt sein dass ober- oder nie dann
beginnen vermögens erscheint aber nicht
dass er eben das eben zum wirklichen
wollen der wille in der erscheinung ist
nie bestimmen es dann immer bestimmt das
heißt erste terminiert durch das
naturgesetz die bestimmung ist schon
geschehen wäre sie nicht geschehens
erschien er nicht ganz billig ist ein
anderer als neigung die scheinbare
erfindung des selbstbestimmten ist keine
empfehlung für eine unfall mehr die
folgerung außen nicht empfindungen
bestimmten kraft sofern der wille sich
selbst bestimmen ist ist sie gar keinen
sinn sein übersee nicht so mögen aber
das bestimmt sein des willens erscheint
und nun entsteht die frage ist jenes für
die möglichkeiten zu berichten als
seinen frust zu lang
zunehmendes selbst bestimmen so einer
gewissen befriedigung oder nicht
befriedigung usa erscheinen ist bestimmt
seine befriedigung oder nicht
befriedigen wer mal wieder wie das sehr
wichtige partie von gerichten nehme ich
das jetzt fichte unterscheidet zwischen
erscheinen und dem willen der würde
erscheint als eine einigung aber die
bestimmung oder dass demente das
erscheint nicht also die aktivität des
bestimmen die freiheit die das freiheits
moment das erscheint nicht sondern der
wille erscheint immer dann wenn er schon
bestimmt ist all das bestimmt sein
das ist also ganz ganz enge entscheidung
verpflichtet
damit versucht jetzt wie ich da auch
diese ganze unterscheidung zwischen
naturgesetz und sieht ein gesetz weiter
aufzuarbeiten und fruchtbar zu machen
für eine tür der freiheit wäre sie nicht
geschehen so sehr schönen nicht als
wildes und als nachkommen die
scheinbaren für selbstbestimmung ist
keine empfindung als der wille als
aktives freies vermögen aber auch als
etwas was das erheben zum wohnen leistet
die erscheint nicht wenn der wille
erscheint dann dieser neigung dann
unterlegt wird dem naturgesetz soja und
noch ein zitat
und das bezieht sich jetzt auf den
fatalismus von carl christian schmid
auch eine ganz klare meinung dazu von
untersuchungen dieser theorie geht herr
kreuzer ist also die besprechung die
rezension zur prüfung des allen lesern
der allgemeinen literatur zeitung dass
die aez sattsam bekannten schnittstelle
geben fatalismus über das ist sehr diese
theorie von der spekulativen seite an
geschenken befriedigen den rezensenten
als geschichte ist klar und einleuchtend
dass sie alle moralität völlig aufhebe
der rezensent das dichte ist über den
zweiten punkt für mich mit ihm
einverstanden und das was herr professor
stehen selbst in der vorrede zu diesem
kuchen zu seiner verteidigung mehr über
sagt hat ihm wenigstens noch ärger als
die anklage geschehen zurechnung schuld
und verdienst fällt mir diese theorien
nach herrn schmitz eigenen geständnisse
weg und wäre es an ihnen zu zeigen wie
man sich dabei noch ein für jede
handlung die nach dem gesetz geurteilt
wird gültiges gesetz denken kann
die moralität welche übrig bleiben soll
ist eben diejenige welche in den
ehemaligen glücks und vollkommen 1
theorien die probleme gut sein ist ein
glück und böse sein 1
also was kritisiert jetzt hier richtig
kritisiert am hinter die journalismus
dass dieser zwar spekulativ befriedigend
ist also spricht theoretisch von der
theoretischen vernunft aber faktisch
unvernunft nicht befriedigt also der
rezensent fichte ist kritisch was jetzt
hier die praktischen grenzen angelangt
rechnung schon im verdienst velbert
diese theorie weg das ist die
integrierte fatalismus wir sind nur
moralisch guten handlung gut in
moralisch bösen während mir nicht gut
nicht verein und die mama die amoralität
trifft den schmied damit zu grunde legt
der ist eigentlich eine teutonische
begriff also gut sein ist ein glück
und würde seinen unglück vielleicht auch
etwas das wir gar nicht selbst in der
hand haben sondern das einfach von außen
zustößt und das widerspricht natürlich
wichtig aber auch ganz
freiheitsverständnis in dem sinn dass
wir opel sind selbst unsere unser
schicksal selbst unsere zukunft
bestimmen können als individuum so das
war jetzt eine kurze darstellung von
fichtes sehr kompakte rezension man muss
dazu sagen wichtig ist hier noch ganz am
anfang seiner entwicklung erwarte erst
später 694 folgejahren seine
wissenschafts lehrer erfasst und wir
werden im laufe des seminars noch ab und
somit nicht befassen
das war jetzt will ich das erste früchte
beitrag zur nach kantischen feierte
ziemlich unbekannte rezession wir wollen
sie ihr thematisieren
ich wünsche meinen zuschauerin
zuschauern war ein
seminarteilnehmerinnen
seminarteilnehmern alles gute zum neuen
jahr